s'il vous plaît en parlant de dangers
étaient partout il faut on oublie quand
même que on a pas oublié d'ailleurs
demain ça fera 2 ans et demi que le
professeur Samuel Paty a été tué après
la tragédie le collège devait être
renommé pourtant rien n'a encore été
fait ça ça me rend fou il devait
renommer le collège ça me le fatigue et
ça n'a pas encore été fait c'est comme à
chaque fois ils viennent tous quand il y
a des drames ils viennent ils viennent
sur le terrain ils annoncent des choses
et on va faire le collège et on va
l'appeler Samuel Paty ça se reproduira
plus on va faire si on va faire ça deux
ans et demi après il y a rien qui a été
faite
des parents qui ont assisté et qui
étaient des élèves notamment et ben ils
sont traumatisés et que peut-être il
faut garder ça
il y a un vrai sentiment de peur c'est à
dire que les collègues de Samuel Paty on
peut en être stigmatisé soit pris pour
cible si changer de nom au niveau local
on a aussi une meilleure Laurent Bros
qui dit que qui peut pas forcer la main
du collège pour rebaptiser pour
rebatiser l'établissement et lui m'a dit
j'ai peur j'ai aujourd'hui je me promène
plus à pied je prenne en voiture et j'ai
peur d'être décapités sur le mur de
Samuel Paty c'est pas un petit fait
divers isolé dans une ville des Yvelines
c'est un c'est un enjeu pour tous
l'éducation nationale pour ça en jeu de
laïcité et donc on leur demande se
positionner de dire si oui ou non ce
collège devait être baptisé et ce que
nier manuel Macron il fait puisqu'ils
ont refusé de se positionner en me
disant la décision revient en collège
non mais non
je trouvais du enfin du président de la
République et du ministre de l'éducation
nationale le Président de la République
en vrai ce sujet ça devrait être
absolument un sort de de fleur de Lens
de tout en fait
lui j'ai jamais rencontré mais les mecs
ça ça doit être une priorité
ça doit être une priorité c'est pas
président de la République le président
de la République il doit pas s'occuper
de ça excusez-moi de vous dire ça bien
sûr il doit juste dire à papa tu fais le
nécessaire mais pas Penga il excusez-moi
mais non mais non mais je préfère je je
savais pas peine de le faire je suis
désolé les mecs excusez-moi il s'adapte
à la couverture médiatique là c'est pas
intéressant on en parle plus dans les
médias donc pourquoi c'est ça avancer
les choses donc on laisse ta direction
on voit tous là-bas c'est pas
intéressant on en parle pas sur comment
parler sans vous allez voir que ça va
bouger je suis sur un certain temps
effectivement Samuel Paty tout le monde
en a parlé on a dit que c'était un héros
mais c'est pas un héros suffisamment
pour renommer le collège
pourquoi que ce collège là moi je vais
plus loin pourquoi que
conflans-sainte-à-oreille
22 lieues allez-y prenez votre et
renommer les collèges que ce monsieur
que ce professeur soit pas mort pour
rien parce que moi pour moi je vais vous
dire une connerie tellement que je suis
pas tellement je suis un culte pour moi
il est comme Charles de Gaulle il est
comme Victor Hugo et comme Jean Jaurès
il est comme des arrêts de bus pour moi
lui 100 €, lui pour moi dans ma tête
pour moi c'est un héros lui sinon on
donne raison à celui qui l'a tué alors
celui qui l'a tué on a peur alors on a
peur du Bataclan alors on a peur de tout
on s'écrit
[Applaudissements]
de son vivant et il est lâché par sa
hiérarchie après sa mort
avec la peur
et le gouvernement c'est pareil
Jean-Baptiste Clément Verlaine machin il
aura le nom des collèges comme il y a
dans des collèges et dans des lycées
dans toute la France bah pourquoi on
attend ouais Conflans oui d'accord
conflans je suis d'accord c'est là-bas
qui a eu le drame c'est on respecte mais
il se met là il faut pas l'oublier c'est
pas l'oublier mais la question c'est
pardon parce que on a peur de quoi en
fait parce que on a peur de ça ils ont
peur de représailles alors ils ont
raison alors les terroristes donc il y a
des menaces de décapitation ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des gens en France
qui menacent notre ordre républicain et
on a pas le droit enfin donc ça va alors
que quand même pardon
le parallèle tout à l'heure entre
l'ultra droite et certains groupes très
très minoritaires fondamentaliste
islamique c'est pas ce dont on parle et
c'est pas
le stream gauche toi non non non je
parlais de ce que là on parle de ça on
va parler de c'est c'est oui alors en
fait il tente de trouver une raison qui
est très mauvaise à mon avis c'est tant
que tous les élèves et les enseignants
qui ont connu Samuel patine ne seront
pas partis sur tous les élèves on ne
renomme pas le collège qui est absurde
c'est à dire c'est un moyen c'est quoi
non mais c'est absurde raison
il faut leur laisser un stage de
décompress surtout que c'est parce
qu'ils ont ils ont peur des représailles
voilà c'est tout pour les raisons c'est
qu'ils ont peur et qui ne sont pas
courageux c'est incroyable ça ça c'est
inadmissible